so there has been reports that may the
12th is the date that finland will
decide to apply to nato is that right
well that date is important
and thank you for having me in the
program
the president of finland has said that
by the may 12th he will make his opinion
public we started this democratic
process almost immediately after
after the russian invasion of ukraine
and it has been a very
thorough parliamentary procedure with a
report from the government to the
parliament on the options
and
indeed applying for nato membership is
one of the options so on the 12th
things are moving they have been moving
of course already before that with
various political parties stating their
opinions and all indeed mps we have 200
members of parliament coming out to the
public and saying openly what they
think about it
you've obviously never felt the need to
apply to join nato before
what's changed
i have to go a little bit back on
history actually almost a thousand years
we were part of the swedish kingdom for
six centuries then we were part of the
russian empire as an
as an um very autonomous um grand duchy
so we have throughout
all of our history being between east
and the west and finland has often been
sort of dragged into conflicts that we
had very little
ownership of that that had very little
to do with finland but more with the big
power politics
and that is why the finns have had a
very pragmatic approach to military
alignment we haven't seen it as a
necessity necessity we might have been
even suspicious about it but now with
the
invasion of ukraine by russia which we
completely completely condemn and which
the finnish population doesn't
understand at all and doesn't accept
the the climate the political climate
and the popular opinion has changed
um this week your foreign ministry has
said a russian army helicopter violated
finland's airspace how concerned are you
about
aggression from russia
when it comes to violations of airspace
we have had plenty of those before
during the past years when we always
react to them and we demand an
explanation
um that is not new we are also quite
prepared for any other type of
influence or influence attempts from
russia during the process of application
if we do to decide to start it
we have
invested in our preparedness and i don't
mean only defense
but the sort of whole of society
approach comprehensive security for
decades and i think we are quite well
prepared for different types of uh
influence including cyber hybrid or
indeed uh violations of our territory
there's obviously a border between
finland and russia we've all seen the
atrocities that have happened
in ukraine
frankly if you're not a member of nato
is finland feeling vulnerable
i wouldn't say vulnerable is the word we
are concerned we are very concerned for
the security structure of europe that we
have built our security around
but as i said we have been investing in
our own national defense for decades we
have quite a robust
defense force both the army the air
force and the navy so in that sense we
are not
overly
worried
what we are concerned about is what this
this attack and this war will mean to
the european security structure in the
future and therefore we have taken this
uh opportunity to consider our route
forward and we shall see where where the
parliamentary and the democratic
decisions lead us
are you confident that if you did apply
to join nato that you would be accepted
reports that the croatian president
saying that he would actually veto
any application
we are following very carefully the
discussion in different major countries
and and embassies including my own have
been tasked to find out what the
political climate in each and every
member state is for the part of the uk i
can say
and that was also uh repeated by tom
tuggenheim just a couple of minutes ago
that uh the british support is very
clear so we have absolutely no no
concerns about about britain whatsoever
each member states and there are 30 of
those in nato is a case of its own and
of course we are looking at each and
every one of them but at the moment i
wouldn't say that we have particular
concerns of any of them
what are you prepared to contribute to
nato if you were to become members
certainly we take our memberships in in
any organization very seriously since
other a rule away nation and a country
we have a strong national defense so i
think our inclusion in nato would
strengthen
the security situation around the baltic
sea
we are also extremely solid democracy uh
the least corrupt country in the world
um and in some fields of technology
including
mobile networks
intelligence quantum intelligence we are
ahead of the field you might say so i
think we have a lot lots to contribute
and just finally obviously the
importance of nato has really been
highlighted with the war in ukraine but
there has been criticism of nato
previously uh by many different um
people of course um that it's too
aggressive that it's provoked russia by
moving troops do you accept any of those
criticisms of how nato has been i think
we see nato as a defense alliance and
and
of course when you plan for defence you
have to
prepare for different alternatives but i
don't think
we uh see in finland see that nato uh
and indeed nato member states can be in
any way blamed
for what has happened in ukraine that
was a russian aggression against a
sovereign neighboring state uh and
completely unwarranted and unquote